hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial de migrantes que preparamos
para ustedes desde necoclí un municipio
en el noroccidente de colombia muy cerca
a la frontera con panamá bienvenidos a
este especial que realizamos junto a
lionel booster y
[Música]
nos encontramos en un punto importante
para el tránsito de emigrantes hacia
centroamérica hasta aquí llegan miles de
personas que buscan cruzar desde
colombia hacia panamá y en ese tránsito
tienen que pasar la peligrosa selva del
darién pero esta no es una ruta nueva lo
nuevo es que hace algunos días se
reportó en este municipio el
represamiento de al menos 15 mil
migrantes que no podían salir de este
lugar pues las lanchas que los
transportan hacia la localidad de sina
de capurganá son insuficientes para
atender tal llegada masiva de migrantes
aquí encontramos a ciudadanos haitianos
en su mayoría procedentes de chile y
brasil también algunos cubanos
venezolanos y un menor número de
africanos veamos a continuación en el
siguiente reporte un panorama general de
lo que pasa en esta localidad de necoclí
un municipio que se encuentra en estado
de calamidad pública
esto es necoclí un viernes de julio en
medio de una pandemia a las siete de la
mañana una larga fila se extiende a la
entrada del muelle de la localidad la
mayoría de los que esperan su turno son
haitianos quienes logran embarcarse hoy
llevan días esperando poder hacerlo
algunos permanecen en esa espera durante
semanas otros llevan incluso un mes el
problema aquí es que no hay
embarcaciones suficientes para llevar a
los miles que se reportan parados en
cocoliche y la situación no parece tener
una pronta solución para ciudadanos que
han cruzado incluso hacia otro
continente con la esperanza de mejorar
sus condiciones de vida y en un país
como colombia que sólo les sirve de
tránsito
hay muchas nacionalidades pero digamos
que
gran número de haitianos cubanos y ya
viene el grupo de los países africanos y
vemos algo de países de
del oriente samil llegó de chile es
profesional estudió mecánica automotriz
pero dice que ese país ya no es una
opción viable para él viajó durante días
y está a punto de salir de colombia
ahora denuncia la demora en la venta de
los pasajes para subir a una lancha la
mayoría de ellos como esa persona que
tiene como tres semanas aquí con un niño
y no se queda plata porque muy difícil a
él y no sé si me entiende porque él
viene de brasil no habla español no sé
si me entiende
ahora quiero denunciar a la empresa que
vende el tiquete no es posible vender un
tiquete cada lunes y hay muchas personas
cada día llegaron como 500 personas y
vender cada lunes que hacer y lo cuento
y tiene el tiquete se venden se venden a
los hoteles para vender a los
inmigrantes haitianos y ahora punto se
vende
conseguir un ticket tiene que ir a un
hotel punto sale un hotel día 15 dólares
diarios no es posible samil señala que
este es un tránsito de alto costo tanto
físico como monetario mínimo mínimo
mínimo más vacas y son dos personas
tener que 525 mil dólares americanos
porque imaginan te llega al en tumbes de
la fuente la ecuador y colombia para
llegar acá cada persona va a catama que
clienta loca 500 dólares americanos
y no todos tienen las mismas opciones
por lo que en esta parada del recorrido
algunas familias ya no cuentan con que
pagar lo que sigue en el camino es el
caso de decir
quiero poder pasar porque estoy agotada
no puedo resistir más es una situación
muy difícil para vivir quiero seguir mi
camino en pines caben line
ella denuncia que la robaron y ya no
tiene con qué pagar un hospedaje para su
familia
la situación migratoria es crítica las
autoridades contaron hasta 15.000
personas represadas en este punto de
colombia entre ellas mujeres embarazadas
y niños una ruta hacia centroamérica que
no es nueva pero que parece olvidada por
el gobierno como medida el ministro de
defensa hizo presencia en una localidad
que necesita una respuesta de carácter
urgente y humanitario
se acordó con la armada nacional con la
alcaldía de acandí con la alcaldía de
turbo y con apoyo de la gobernación el
establecimiento de un nuevo embarcadero
desde el cual podrán partir de forma
organizada y con ese registro previo
todos los migrantes que habían hacer su
tránsito
con esta solución que plantea el
gobierno el alcalde del municipio de
necoclí estima que se podría dar
respuesta a la crisis en los pocos días
simplemente tenemos disponibles con los
empresarios de turbo aproximadamente
unas 32 embarcaciones yo pienso que eso
cuesta 32 embarcaciones podemos decir de
que podemos evacuar por ahí 34 días y
quedamos sin un migrante quien municipio
sin embargo la realidad es otra justo el
día después a este anuncio no hubo
salida de embarcaciones para transportar
a los migrantes y los tickets están
vendidos en su totalidad hasta el lunes
9 de agosto
cuanto más tendrán entonces que esperar
en necoclí
las historias particulares de los
migrantes que encontramos en este lugar
son diversas pero tienen algo en común y
es que buscan un futuro mejor para ellos
y sus familias llama la atención la
situación de algunos haitianos que
salieron desde hace varios años de su
país y que ahora vuelven a emigrar es
una situación que también comparten con
algunos venezolanos que están haciendo
lo mismo
veamos sus razones a continuación
remy es un haitiano que quería formarse
y trabajar por su comunidad pero la
economía empeoró y con ella las
oportunidades laborales en su país el
debía buscar el sustento para su familia
y por eso el micro estaba trabajando
enseñando esos procesos en matemáticas
física y química allá en haití y le dejó
todo el trabajo trabajar con un barrio
vocalizaciones allá para ayudar a los
niños los derechos de los niños
el vih y todo eso si dejo todo porque ya
dijo que hay más oportunidad para surgir
para tener lo mínimo lo básico como ser
si ser humano en 2017 cuando llegó a
chile trabajó como panadero y las cosas
parecían tomar rumbo pero dice que todo
cambio desde la pandemia y que cada vez
fue más difícil renovar la documentación
para permanecer en el país yo creo que
no es futuro para mi futuro de qué
sentido no hay por trabajar sino yo
tengo capacitaciones para trabajar en
cualquier lado de cualquier lado de lo
básico de la pega que un chileno no
quiere hacer puede ser pero si yo quiero
de verdad surgir y tiene más oportunidad
que todo el mundo sabe que estado unido
si uno quiere uno tiene la fuerza para
trabajar y va a lograr cosas que nunca
esperé en la vida y por eso me decidió
de dejar chile y voy para estado ido a
necoclí también llegaron haitianos
procedentes de brasil inmigrantes que
como wilmer dejaron su país hace 7 años
y ahora vuelven a mirar
él está a sólo días de cruzar la selva
del darién la gente dice que hay muchos
con el camino pero yo no sé por qué yo
no lo sé porque dice la gente que tengo
con el camino un camino que también yo
no tengo miedo a nada más temprano
encontramos a levy y rosmary justo el
día de su llegada a nico click salimos
de venezuela por la crisis económica y
política que existe y fuimos hasta perú
pero lo que es la xenofobia aunado al
ahorita la política el nuevo presidente
que eligieron el perú este decidimos
salir pues porque vemos como que es lo
mismo que ha sucedido en venezuela va a
suceder probablemente allí no no
queremos repetir pues lo mismo pues
queremos más seguridad para nosotros y
para nuestros hijos en otra familia
migran junto a un grupo de venezolanos y
consiguieron pasajes para pasar hacia
capurganá en pocos días hoy se preparan
para el viaje marchetto ahí es comida
comida
lo que más pesa y los zapatos son las
cosas allí pero ya sabemos que como con
tres cositas nada más tenemos que salir
y pues ya volver a pasar rápido a punto
de embarcar levy no descarta la
posibilidad de retornar algún día a su
país o por supuesto a mi país lo vamos
demasiados y muchos años ahorita tengo
38 años ahí volver es una ilusión pues
voy a estar con mi familia con los míos
es duro
por tanto decisiones
[Música]
en este día salen del muelle de necoclí
pero aún les quedan kilómetros de
recorrido rumbo a eeuu
de esto se acabó
una de las principales actividades
económicas en necoclí es el turismo sin
embargo la gran afluencia de migrantes
hasta este lugar ha cambiado esa
realidad y transformado la forma de
sustento de sus habitantes se trata de
un beneficio de doble vía que beneficia
tanto a los migrantes como a los locales
sin embargo los extranjeros denuncian
algunos cobros excesivos
un municipio turístico que parece
recuperarse económicamente en pandemia
por la migración y uno de los sectores
aunque colapsado ante la masiva llegada
pero al tiempo más beneficiado es el del
transporte marítimo que cada día embarca
en promedio a unos 800 migrantes cada
uno de ellos paga 50 dólares para
subirse a una lancha pero en estos
momentos los prestadores de servicios
tanto el sector transporte como hotelero
y de restaurantes han visto pues muy
influenciado este tipo de economía ha
ayudado mucho claro venimos de una
pandemia donde estuvimos casi un año
cerrados y esto ha ayudado mucho a la
actividad económica el comercio se
adaptó en la vía que lleva al muelle se
venden artículos para sobrevivir en el
intransitable tapón del darién me dedico
al comercio médico venderle lo que ellos
necesitan para para su travesía allá en
la selva como pueden ver vendemos la
prima que para espantar los zancudos las
linternas
la boya para cocinar esa estufa de gas
que la necesita muy mucho lo que poco
está a la venta son productos de
bioseguridad aquí el hobby 19 parece no
existir y aunque los comerciantes
aseguran no aprovecharse de la situación
los migrantes denuncian abusos en los
cobros el pueblo colombiano aquí no se
molesta nadie no se hace racista nadie
pero igual no va a ser racista no llevó
que todo esto es gañán todo está ganando
las casas de familias son ahora también
un negocio los hoteles están a tope y
los propietarios dispusieron sus
viviendas para recibir a los migrantes
que deben cancelar entre 10 y 20 dólares
por persona para el hospedaje
pese a que la llegada de emigrantes
hasta esta zona en el noroccidente de
colombia no es algo nuevo las vías
marítimas para el transporte de ellos
siguen siendo insuficientes un nuevo
embarcadero y más lancha sería la
solución que plantea el gobierno de
colombia para responder a esta crisis
migratoria que se registra en este lugar
recordemos además que colombia es un
país de tránsito para estos migrantes
hasta aquí migrantes de france 24
gracias por acompañarnos en este
programa especial que preparamos junto a
mi compañero lionel to share y recuerde
que este y otros programas usted puede
verlos en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]